today on the matt wall show we will
discuss the problem of whiteness
i don't think whiteness is a problem but
we're told that it is in fact a recent
uh
paper in the psychoanalytic journal
argues that it's really a disease which
has to be cured so we'll talk about that
also five headlines including
the cop who flipped a pregnant woman's
car on the highway because she didn't
pull over fast enough during a traffic
stop
is that proper procedure and dr fauci
claims
that he himself is science made flesh
to question him is to question science
in our daily cancellation we'll deal
with the new york times article that
generated controversy
because it's supposedly suggested that
you shouldn't have a lot of obese
or depressed friends people didn't like
that for some reason but i think it
actually makes a good point i'll explain
why
that and much more today on the matt
wall show
[Music]
now word from legacy box you know those
of us who are of of a certain age
of a ripe old age ancient and decrepit
like over the age of 30.
we may have a lot of family family
memories that
uh are sort of trapped now on antiquated
technology
camcorder tapes physical pictures i hate
to say physical picture is antiquated
technology but it sort of is
um and uh and the problem is those
things degrade they get destroyed they
you can lose them
you don't have easy access to them so
what do you do about that well you get
legacy box legacy box is a super simple
mail-in service to have all of your
video tapes camcorder tapes
film reels and pictures digitally
preserved on a thumb drive dvd or the
cloud
legacy box is a way for you to easily
and affordably digitally preserve your
pass
your past and the process is very very
simple i've done it myself
all you do is just pack up your stuff
send it out their team digitizes
everything they send it back to you
and uh it really is that easy so you've
got to do this and i wouldn't wait i
would do it now
you can get started preserving your
family's legacy today go to
legacybox.com
walsh to get an incredible 50 off your
first order but today
buy today to take advantage of this
exclusive offer send in when you're
ready legacy box is great for you it's
great for someone you love
so again go to legacybox.com walsh and
save 50
while supplies last one of the most
consequential
and as we'll see most dangerous
innovations
of america's race hustler constituency
is the invention of the term
whiteness now we used to hear constant
condemnations of alleged white supremacy
even though white supremacy
as a belief system is nearly
non-existent in this country and as a
legal principle it's entirely
non-existent
white supremacists clan members
neo-nazis and the like are small
scattered insignificant as for the law
there are no laws on the books today
anywhere in any state or jurisdiction
that enshrine or codify white supremacy
despite what you may have heard
of course we still hear about this
supposed problem of white supremacy but
many of those who once focused on
fighting that make-believe scourge
have moved on and are these days intent
on slaying the dragon known as whiteness
increasingly advocates for so-called
racial justice
have widened their lens beyond white
supremacy to now include
this much broader category which would
seem to encompass
all white people white supremacy
is a belief system it's a fringe belief
system but it's a belief system all the
same
whiteness on the other hand in its most
literal sense simply means
the state or quality of being white
and this sheds disturbing light on for
example all of the college courses with
titles like
the problem of whiteness and the calls
from academics and activists to quote
abolish whiteness
it's not simply white supremacy
thereafter anymore but whiteness
itself the state and quality of being a
white person
recall that now infamous segment with uh
mara gay
on msnbc where she discusses her terror
at seeing pickup trucks with american
flags
and everybody zeroed in on those
comments because they were deranged and
idiotic
but i actually think the bigger problem
was something that we kind of missed it
was it was this part right here
the reality is here that we have a large
percentage of the american population i
don't know how big it is but we have
tens of millions of trump voters
who continue to believe that
their rights as citizens are under
threat by simple virtue of having to
share the democracy
with others i think as long
as they see americanness
as the same as one with whiteness
this is going to continue we have to
figure out how to get every american a
place at the table
in this democracy but how to separate
americanness america from whiteness
separate america from whiteness how do
you intend to do that
and what should be done with all of us
white people once we've been
separated this sort of talk begins to
sound almost
murderous and if you think that's an
overstatement keep listening because it
gets worse
the way that race activists get around
the obviously horrific implications of
this kind of talk is the same way they
get around everything else
by manipulating language to obscure the
meaning of the words that they use
that's why if you go beyond the
dictionary and you try to find a
definition of whiteness from the people
who use it so often
you'll end up with a lot of hazy
indeterminate ramblings like this from
the alberta civil liberties
research center quoting a feminist
sociologist named ruth franken
frankenberg
it says whiteness is quote a dominant
cultural space with enormous political
significance
with the purpose to keep others on the
margin
okay if that doesn't clear things up the
national museum of african american
history and culture
has this to say about the cancer known
as whiteness
quote whiteness and white racialized
identity refer to the way that white
people their customs culture and beliefs
operate as the standard by which all
other groups are compared
whiteness is also at the core of
understanding race in america whiteness
and the normalization of weight white
racial identity throughout america's
history
have created a culture where non-white
persons are seen as inferior or abnormal
this white dominant culture also
operates as a social mechanism
that grants advantages to white people
since they can navigate society both by
feeling normal
and being viewed as normal persons who
identify as white rarely have to think
about their racial identity because they
live within a culture where whiteness
has been normalized blah blah blah
meanwhile dr monica t williams writes
for psychology today
that whiteness is quote an unfairly
privileged exclusionary category based
on physical features most notably a lack
of melanin
so that brings us back to whiteness is
the state and quality of being white
for this reason the good doctor explains
white people
are not allowed to be proud of their
racial identity she says that
she will in her magnanimity
permit you to be proud of say your
specific german heritage
or uh because you know there's nothing
problematic there apparently
or your french canadian culture but you
must not be
proud to be white in general because
quote
whiteness is a forced group membership
that originated by oppressing people of
color
i mean whiteness itself
the physical state of whiteness
originated through oppression
that's what she says but can black
people like herself
be proud of their race why well of
course they can she says quote
people may then ask why is it okay to be
proud of being black but not white
this is because pride and blackness
represents pride in the accomplishments
and resilience
of a racialized group in the face of
continual oppression
it is healthy for black people to
celebrate these small victories to
maintain their self-esteem
despite pervasive social messages of
inferiority
well that's it then a hallowed mental
health professional has spoken it's
healthy for black people to be proud of
who they are
but it's not healthy for white people
the most healthy mental state for a
white person is one of suffocating
never-ending guilt and shame
this view has become especially common
among psychiatrists psychologists and
psychoanalysts
the entire psycho industry seems to be
fueled by two primary assumptions number
one
gender is fluid and number two whiteness
is bad
these are also the two primary
assumptions of academia the media
corporate america
and the united states government but
it's especially hazardous in the mental
health field because
these are the professionals to whom the
most mentally vulnerable people are
entrusted
and that gives us even more of a reason
to be equal parts disgusted and
terrified by a paper very recently
published
in the distinguished allegedly and also
peer-reviewed journal of the american
psychoanalytic association
in the paper a guy named dr donald moss
who's a faculty member of the san
francisco center for psychoanalysis
and the new york psychoanalytic
institute shares his thoughts on the
topic of quote
having whiteness now if the phrase
having whiteness
makes white identity sound like a
disease
as if someone might have whiteness in
the same way that they have cancer or
chickenpox
well that's exactly the point here is
the abstract
it says quote whiteness is a condition
one first acquires and then one has a
malignant
parasitic-like condition to which white
people have a particular
susceptibility the condition is
foundational generating characteristics
character characteristic ways of being
in one's body and one's mind
and in one's world parasitic whiteness
renders its most it's uh hosts his hosts
appetites
voracious insatiable and perverse these
deformed appetites
particularly target non-white people
once established these appetites are
nearly impossible to eliminate
effective treatments of whiteness
consists of a combination of psychic
and social historical interventions such
interventions can reasonably aim
only to reshape whiteness's infiltrated
appetites
to reduce their intensity redistribute
their aims and occasionally turn those
aims
towards the work of reparation when
remembered and represented the ravages
wreaked by the chronic condition
can function either as a warning never
again or as a temptation
great again memorialization alone
therefore is no guarantee against
regression listen to this part
there is not yet a permanent cure
a permanent cure for whiteness
and you thought my choice of the word
murderous was an exaggeration
in fact it was an understatement
probably should have said genocidal
here we have medical professionals
speaking openly about finding a
permanent cure for a certain racial
identity
they are just one half step away from
calling it a final solution
and if this was not all bone shelling
enough i should mention that dr moss has
been delivering his thoughts on
whiteness
on having the whiteness disease in talks
to college students psychoanalysts and
social workers
tickets are only forty dollars by the
way if you're interested
now you don't really need to go back
very far in history to see where this
sort of thing leads
our fallen species has tragically
attempted many experiments
through the centuries with casting an
entire group or race of people
as villains as subhumans as scapegoats
as the cause of all social ills
this has happened many times throughout
history and so we know
that it never results in anything but
bloodshed and misery it can't possibly
come to any other conclusion
there is never a happy ending to this
kind of thing
it's impossible the final chapter of
this book is written in advance
but we keep making the same mistake
anyway
now let's get to our five headlines
i think over the past year especially
people have really been
thinking about being prepared in the
event
of an emergency and now is certainly a
better time
than ever to be prepared with long-term
nutritional food options and that's what
ready wise
is all about ready wise has many options
like emergency meals that you might need
they've also got freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient on-the-go
nutrition they've also got adventure
meals
uh if you especially in the summertime
you're going out hiking and camping
whatever it is other outdoor activities
you can bring those with you as well
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable you can order online and
have
nutritious meals shipped directly to
your doorstep when government resources
are strained it can be days if not weeks
before fresh food is available you don't
want to put yourself in a position
where you're relying on the government
to help you we know that they
are not always exactly johnny on the
spot in fact oftentimes they're not
ready wise uses the finest ingredients
and latest food preparation technology
to ensure optimal taste
and freshness so if you want to take
advantage of this this week my listeners
can get 10
off at readywise.com when entering walsh
at checkout or by calling 855-475-3089
brady weiss is a 30-day no questions
asked return policy so there's no risk
in taking the initiative to get you and
your family prepared today
that's readywise
promo r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e.com walsh get 10
off
all right you know one uh i'm just
realizing
on a slightly less important topic one
of the disadvantages of having our
stazzy new camera angle
uh is that they've taken away my fake
daily wire family
which i just realized they've been
taking i had my you know my pictures
here
of my fake friends and family that were
assigned to me when i came to the daily
wire i didn't
but here's the here's one of the
pictures why can't this still be on my
desk
there's there's my um there's gertrude
and felix the guy is gertrude don't make
assumptions
on their tandem bicycle i would look at
this picture every day and it would
bring me it would warm my heart and
bring me joy
to remember my times with these
imaginary friends
and now i can't have them um all right
i think i just broke it okay so you guys
know
that we are defenders and supporters of
the police over here
on the mat wall show and um
obviously though supporting and
defending the police
when they're being unjustly attacked
which happens a lot
but that also doesn't mean that there's
never an occasion where a cop does a bad
thing
obviously that does happen and when that
does happen
they should be held accountable now the
problem is that this
this the word accountability we'll
remember
lebron james tweeted out the picture of
a cop who saved a a black girl's life
by shooting another black girl who's
trying to stab her to death
and he had that word accountability
putting his his the cops
picture out there putting his life in
jeopardy potentially
so for the the race hustlers and blm and
guys like lebron james
accountability for police means that
they're always wrong no matter what they
do
even if they act heroically and save
someone's life they're still wrong and
their lives should be destroyed that's
what they mean when they say
accountability
and that's a problem because there is
such a thing as
actual accountability and it is
important for everybody
and especially for agents of the state
and police officers are agents of the
state that's their job
and the badge and the gun confers power
and authority
and it's important for us as members of
an allegedly free society to hold agents
of the state
responsible and accountable when they
actually violate um
you know violate their their duties and
and abuse their power
so here's one such case this is from fox
it says an arkansas woman is suing an
arkansas state police officer
who she says quote negligently performed
a pursuit intervention technique
pit maneuver that resulted in her car
flipping over on the highway at 60 miles
per hour in july of 2020. we have the
video we'll play it in a second here
her name is nicole harper she was
pregnant at the time and she was clocked
going 84 miles an hour in a 70 mile per
hour zone
last summer on the highway so she's
going 84 to 70. i
i confess i've gone yeah i have off and
i'm not saying that you should do this
this is not a recommendation but uh
when when the speed limit gets to 70 i
kind of treat that as no speed limit at
all i figure once you get to that point
the speed limit is more of a suggestion
again i'm not saying that's actually the
law
i confess i i will treat it that way so
i've have many times gone
over 84 certainly in a 70. uh it's not
that you know it's
to be especially on a sort of empty
highway
going 84 to 70. it's i guess the point
is
there's no reason to think by the fact
that she's going 84 and 70
that she's some sort of violent
dangerous criminal
there's no reason to think that this is
anything more than a normal
usually law-abiding american who's just
committing a rather minor
traffic infraction but that's not how
she was treated
within seconds of arkansas state police
officer rodney dunn turning on his
patrol cruiser's overhead lights
harper pulled over to the right lane
turned on her emergency blinkers and
slowed to 60 miles per hour
in fact let's just play let's start
playing this now
nicole harper was driving home on the
i-67 and is alleged to have been clocked
for speeding by senior corporal rodney
dunn who claims that she fled
but in the video we see an obvious
decrease in speed as harper pulls into
the right lane and activates her turn
signal
she claims it was to indicate she was
going to exit the interstate
as the area had a reduced shoulder
regardless of harper's actions
and indications that she would stop
corporal dunn
initiates a pit maneuver
[Music]
okay so there he there he is going up
he's gonna he's gonna
kind of ram into the car
that just yep and then it skid this is
on the highway
okay did they hit the inside okay all
right
so he rams the car he does the pit
maneuver
and this is something you see if you
watch you know you see videos of
high-speed chases and they're
pursuing uh violent criminal uh in fact
i mean like i i should say that
oftentimes you watch these
these chases and they don't do that
they'll they'll follow a criminal
someone who they know is a violent felon
a fugitive or whatever they'll follow
them for miles and miles and miles
before they resort to something like
that
um and sometimes it's not even a high
speed chase
you'll see these you'll see these the
cars are going away like 40 miles an
hour and the cops are all just
uh following behind because oftentimes
they're reluctant to execute a maneuver
like that
even if it is a known violent criminal
because you might kill someone doing it
here they did this this officer did to
this woman
just because of a speeding violation and
now we have
this this also makes it all the more
disturbing i think
we have um you can hear the audio now
you don't really see it you don't see it
but
here is the officer after this woman
crawls out of the wreckage
here's how that interaction happened why
when people don't stop for emergency
vehicles we
end this right here right now before you
get further into
congested traffic all you had to do was
slow down and stop
i did slow down i turned on my hazard
yeah this is just completely insane
um though okay
and you hear that he doesn't even appear
to be concerned
there's a she says she's pregnant you
flipped her vehicle
and he's not even saying are you okay he
said well hey this is what happens
you didn't pull over right away and you
can clearly see in the video that it is
a it's a reduced
shoulder there's not a lot of room so
she probably figured
it's it's it's night time it's dark uh
there's a reduced shoulder not a lot of
room
uh it's not safe to pull over and so
what she does instead and you saw it in
the video
she does she she goes into the right
lane she reduces her speed
she puts on her hazards clearly
signaling that she is
trying to comply she's just looking for
a safe place
and it's not like she went for 30
minutes two minutes later
he rams the car and flips her
she hadn't even made it to an exit yet
there was an exit a mile up the road
when he flipped the car clearly she's
looking for an exit
obviously and he flips it by the way
before anyone would consider defending
the police on this one
here's the department of public safety
in arkansas
they have a nice handy document telling
you what to do
when you are stopped by law enforcement
this is the department of health of
safety in arkansas this is what they say
what to do when you're stopped by a law
enforcement officer
number one pull over to the right side
of the road activate your turn signal or
emergency flashers to indicate to the
officer
that you're seeking a safe place to stop
that's it that's exactly what she did
she put on the indication that she's
seeking a safe place
so the officer should know from that
signal which she is following the law
and doing it that she's looking for a
safe place and if she hasn't stopped yet
it's because she
doesn't think this looks safe and i
would agree with her if i was in her
spot i would have done exactly the same
thing
if there's a if there's a small shoulder
that barely fits a vehicle
and it's dark on a highway when other
cars are going 70 miles an hour i'm not
pulling over right there
it's not only unsafe for you it unsafe
for the officer too it could get clipped
because he's gonna while he's engaging
with you he's gonna be standing in the
in the highway in a lane
i if i were her i would have thought for
his sake
i need to go and pull somewhere where
there's enough room for him at least to
stand next to the car and talk to me
without standing in a
in in in a lane on a dark highway
that this to me is totally unexcusable
and i would put this in the i you know i
would put this in the category of as far
as
by the way this cop still has a job i
mean this is one not only should he lose
his job but he should be on
this should be criminal charges there
are a lot of people on lines and this is
attempted murder
it's clearly not attempted murder i
don't think he was trying to kill her
but it's criminal negligence because he
obviously didn't care that much if he
did um i would put this in the
in the uh in the category because it's
like a daniel shaver
shaver the titania jefferson she was the
woman who was sitting in her own house
minding her business and she was shot
through the window by a cop
now in both those cases somebody was
killed nobody was here thank god
but um this is this is like
that those cases in in justin being
completely
indefensible and obviously instances of
a police officer abusing his power um
so she's going to be a very rich woman
after this and she deserves to be
thank god as far as i know the baby was
okay
it's not mentioned in the article i
assume if she suffered a miscarriage
that would be mentioned in the lawsuit
so
i it's i've never seen anything like
that
and that's another important point
though right because
is this case does this case mean that
there needs to be sweeping reforms to
law enforcement across the nation
um unless you're telling me this happens
all the time is the first time i've ever
seen anything like that
i don't know about you this seems to be
one officer who did something that
almost no other police officer would do
in that situation
so the changes and penalties should fall
to him specifically
all right let's go to uh
number two we have footage just want to
show you this
footage from a blm protest in chicago
or whatever you call this i think we
have the footage here this is from um
a few days ago okay here we go
i just want to show you this now here's
a police officer he's driving along he's
going slowly
this is a police officer's actually
trying to preserve human life
um but you've got the uh the protesters
the activists for racial justice
on top of the police cruiser twerking
there's like three
three of these uh women on top of the
police cruiser twerking
and of course you see you see footage
like this all the time at these blm
protests
riots um and i don't even know what they
were protesting over it doesn't matter
it was almost certainly something stupid
but
is you see that in the question as
always
is is this how you behave when you're
scared to death of the police
because these are the same people the
reason they're out there is that they're
saying that the cops are hunting them
and killing them and everything
um is so if you're terrified of police
officers
is that what you do you get up on a
police
cruiser and twerk what is this twerking
as a defense mechanism
uh for me i'll just say there have only
been a few times in my life
maybe when i've gotten so scared that i
twerked
as a defense mechanism it's not common
and and you might argue that the fact
that they're behaving that way shows
that they have
zero fear of the police at all
um all right number three now let's get
to this
dr fauci i don't think we need any real
setup uh to this
i just want to play this for you and
it kind of speaks for itself here it is
what is your level of concern that we're
going to
discredit public health officials to the
point of
you know look at russia they actually
have a good vaccine
and none of their citizens will take it
because they don't trust their own
government
right it's very dangerous chuck because
a lot of what you're seeing
as attacks on me quite frankly are
attacks on science
because all of the things that i have
spoken about consistently from the very
beginning
have been fundamentally based on science
sometimes those things were inconvenient
truths
for people and there was pushback
against me
so if you are trying to do you know get
at
me as a public health official and a
scientist
you're really attacking not only dr
anthony fauci you're attacking science
and anybody that looks at what's going
on
clearly sees that you have to be asleep
not to see that that is what's going on
science and the truth are being attacked
i am science i am science
you attack me you attack science
my god in heaven
this is full-blown megalomania
a surprise coming for you we already
knew that that was the case for him but
the only difference here is that usually
fauci
while he's clearly all along been a
narcissist and a megalomaniac drunk on
his own power and everything else
it's been very clear all along he he
would usually still try to hide behind
this sweet old grandfather i'm going to
be the reasonable guy
thing and he'll and he'll do that while
um supporting you know
policies and and uh making statements
that result in
you know untold suffering of of millions
of americans
but usually hides behind that and this
is one of those
ripping the mask off moments where he he
just comes out and says if you attack me
you attack
truth and science this is north korea
level
stuff where if you
if you criticize a public official
someone who works for the government
you are criticizing truth itself
just think about what it requires
psychologically
to not only think that but to say it out
loud
on tv
i guess he's he's just done with it
because
he uh he knows that he's dr fauci dammit
and you're not supposed to criticize him
and he's tired of being criticized
because he's always right even if he
says contradictory things
even if he says one thing one minute an
op
a a completely contradictory thing the
next minute
meanwhile he's emailing and sending
private emails that contradict both of
the things that he just that he said
publicly
[Music]
it's all science it's all truth
how does that work exactly because if dr
fauci is contradicting himself
and disagreeing with himself and we want
to make sure that we agree with dr fauci
all the time
then inevitably we're also going to to
agree with dr fauci is also to disagree
with him
because whatever he's saying now it's
almost certain that he said the opposite
of that at some other point
so what do i do if i want to make sure
that i'm a good
a good uh cult member and i stay loyal
to dr fauci i don't know what i'm
supposed to do
if he's saying you know wear a mask now
but before he said no you don't need to
wear a mask and you shouldn't wear one
so to agree with them now i'm i'm
contradicting the the dr fauci of uh
of march 2020.
well i guess the answer to that riddle
is that the truth and the science
changes whatever he says that it does
this is total madness of course uh in in
reality
as we have tried to establish many times
science is a process
science is not an institution okay it is
it is not a deity
speaking from on high science is not
mount olympus um science is not a
uh you know a sage or a guru that you
climb a mountain and you consult oh dear
science
tell us the truth and science certainly
is not a person
and most certainly is not a person who
works with government
it's a process of discovering
the the uh in understanding
the way that the physical world works
that's what science is
and an important part of the scientific
process is asking questions
and being critical
critical not in the sense of being
insulting although if you want to be
insulting to dr fauci go for it there's
a lot to insult
but critical in the sense of you know
not simply accepting everything that
you're told that is the un's that is an
anti-scientific approach
but that's how dr fauci views himself
and that's how he's been treated
where he is the science
all right next this is from the daily
caller it says establishment media has
been conspicuously silent on hunter
biden's alleged use of the n-word in
text messages obtained
by the daily mail and reported on
tuesday searching nbc news the
washington post cnn
and the new york times returns no
results related to the text messages
the story has been covered by the daily
caller forbes fox news new york post
and other outlets nbc news the
washington post cnn new york times did
not respond to a request for comment
just days after president joe biden
delivered an emotional anti-racism
speech in tulsa oklahoma the daily mail
published text messages
where hunter biden allegedly called his
white lawyer the n-word
and talked about his penis in one text
message hunter biden reportedly asked
his lawyer corporate attorney george
missions how much money he owed and said
n-word you better not be charging me
hennessy rates
messiahs reportedly replied that made me
snarf my coffee
snarf i'm way more concerned with by the
use of the word snarf here
than the n word because i don't know
what that word means
exactly um hunter biden addressed his
white lawyer as
uh the n word with an a at the end
multiple times um used phrases like
true dat n-word and bantered i only love
you because you're black
okay and these were text messages i
think that date back like 20
2018. and uh
as of the writing of this daily caller
article
this story had not been reported as they
said um in any of these mainstream media
outlets they just ignored it completely
it's not even like they reported it and
then buried it or they
just tossed off a a little short
two paragraph story and then buried it
no they've ignored it entirely
um and yeah so i i'm kind of two minds
on this because on one hand
if this was don jr and
his text messages saying the n-word even
yeah
he's using the n-word here in a jovial
joking manner
and he's talking to and about a white
person
even so we all know that if this was don
jr or really any other prominent
conservative
and um they were found to have used the
n-word in that context or any context
uh it would be a huge story and their
life would be destroyed and everything
else right we
we all know that and we've been told
many times by the cultural powers that
be
that context doesn't matter it doesn't
matter what context you use the word
papa john lost his job he lost
everything and is now a pariah because
he used the n-word
just in quoting somebody else who used
it
and in the context of using it he was
actually he was critical of the person
for using it
and he lost his job for that so
um but we also know that papa john was
uh was i don't know if he's actually
republican but he was he was a suspected
republican
so there's a definitely a double
standard here that's for sure
however um
it also doesn't matter at all what what
words hunter biden used in a text
message exchange
i don't care at all it does not matter
and i also have to confess to you and i
know i'm going to put myself in the
minority a little bit
among conservatives and especially
conservatives and media
and i've been saying this since the
campaign i i
don't fully understand the right's
focus on hunter um
i think it's a bad political strategy i
don't think it works
because of course all the people on the
right who are sort of like feigning
offense over this they're not really
offended because they know who cares
doesn't matter at all um
but they're they're kind of fainting it
because they're trying to make a point
and i get that
but at the same time i just the the
focus on hunter biden i think is
is kind of foolish uh you're not gonna
land any hits
on joe biden by talking about his
loser crackhead son who's who's not a
public official
is not in the white house officially
right
or hasn't i should say has not been
given a job in the administration as far
as i know
you know donald trump gave a lot of his
kids job official jobs in the
administration hunter biden hasn't been
given that as far as i know
um and uh we all understand that he's a
loser
so to keep going back to this well look
at this other loser thing that hunter
biden did it just doesn't
nobody cares yeah the media is gonna
ignore it but
i'm kind of ignoring it too and i'm not
left-wing media but
simply because i don't think it matters
and whatever political advantage you
think you get by talking about hunter
biden i don't think it's there
i said this during the campaign with uh
the final weeks
of the campaign and it's time to make
our our closing argument against joe
biden right
and what were so many people in
right-wing media doing their closing
argument was all about hunter biden's
laptop and i'm not saying that that
wasn't a story i'm not saying there
wasn't potentially a scandal there
i just don't think that that should have
been the closing argument and i said
that
and i think i was proven right
the arguments against joe biden should
be about joe biden himself and there's a
lot that can be said
and about his administration
all right let's move now to reading the
youtube comments
uh this one says i don't understand why
no one supports matt's proposal to
restrict access to voting
to those who can pass a test i might not
even qualify
and i'm still in favor of it yeah i said
that no one that i'm
very much on on the margins on the
fringes
as someone who actually believes in
restricting voting rights based on
competence right um i'm on the fringes
in terms of
you know people in the public eye
but just average people on the street i
think yeah i think actually if you talk
to them a lot of them will say
that actually makes a lot of sense to
have some sort of test some sort of way
to weed out people from the voting booth
who are
absolute ignoramuses so i guess i should
have qualified that
um
mr train says mr walsh you're starting
to or m train i should say
you're starting to grow on me i didn't
really care for your style in the
beginning
your sarcasm and humor i find more
necessary
than originally realized well
it took you this long to understand that
and for that reason
you're banned uh but thanks thanks for
being here anyway
big mama says matt i've got four kids
like you our oldest is six and our
youngest is almost two
he woke up and started singing good god
almighty from his crib and it quickly
got them all singing
and dancing along it was the most
glorious way to wake up
it is you know uh yeah i talked
yesterday about how my kids my kids wake
up singing every single morning
early in the morning like before before
before sunrise sometimes
and i i realize objectively that it's a
very
sweet and innocent thing and a beautiful
thing because they're so excited
and then i feel bad when i'm annoyed by
it i feel bad being annoyed by my kids
joy
but it's just when i'm woken up at 5 30
a.m
even if i'm being woken up by joy it's
hard to not be a little bit annoyed
and finally gregory fairchild says matt
just watch two hours of history channel
on the aztecs and they boast
of them as a very moral society who took
their religion very seriously
well they did take it seriously to the
tune of
you know ripping out people's hearts
left and right
they emphasized aztecs were not savages
funny how they go through amazing
acrobatics to downplay
filleting the skin of people and wearing
it as a fertility ritual
not to mention cutting the beating
hearts out of many
people who are young children that must
be made to cry before killing
no savages there what they would
consider
savage scares me yeah that's
that that is certainly savage behavior
and it doesn't matter who's doing it
we should be able to agree with that but
the
the real annoying thing with something
like the aztecs you look at the
barbarity
the the oppression inflicted
by civilizations like the aztec
civilization
the real excuse that we're given from
the left
is that we should see them in it we
should see that in a historical context
that's what we're told i mean we can't
judge them by the standards of today
so the aztecs are capturing thousands
and thousands of people at a time
dragging them up the temple steps
putting them on the stone slab pulling
out the knife
ripping out their heart while they're
still alive uh yeah they did that but
it's you know
them doing that in the 1400s is
different than if someone did it today
that's the argument
and i could almost go along with that
now it was still
evil in the 1400s and they should have
known better
but i could go along with the idea that
we should apply some historical
perspective even to something as
horrific as that if you were also
applying historical
perspective to everyone else
but when it comes to the spanish or any
other european settlers um
they don't get the advantage of
historical perspective
so if we're talking about indians we we
should not judge them by the standards
of today
if we're talking about white people of
uh or europeans of
500 600 years ago they get judged by the
standards of today
that's the problem that is the
definition of a double standard
you know it's no secret that the amount
of content from the daily wire is
growing rapidly both in numbers
and in quality uh from our investigative
journalism to our sports column to uh
now my incredibly altruistic podcast
where i save abuela's
i save the world really change the world
one abuela at a time
there's just so much to see so much to
hear and read so much content i mean
it's it's like a sweatshop here it's uh
they've got us chained to our desks
they're saying put out the content more
content
um and not exactly like that but almost
and
you gotta you gotta be a part of you
wanna be part of the action so now you
can get it all on the daily wire app
even if you're not a daily wire
subscriber you'll be the first to know
what's trending with
mobile notifications for the latest news
and all of your favorite content only a
touch away so download the daily wire
app and stay up to speed with the
freshest conservative voices around no
matter where you are speaking of more
content
um if you're worried about not getting
enough of my
incredibly reasonable and wise takes and
opinions especially
um concerning aliens and abuelas those
are like two things i focus on but other
issues as well
then you don't need to fear any longer
that's because i've started a weekly
newsletter which will grace your inbox
once a week
with some tips fun facts updates an
introspective look into the dark inner
workings
of my mind and um and the occasional
mean tweet as well it's all in there
it's really just rambling stream of
consciousness
but that's what the that's what the kids
want with the newsletters these days i'm
told
so you saw the lengths i'm willing to go
for abuelas so what
lengths will i go for a newsletter for
you you got to find out so go to
dailywire.com
matt walsh report and subscribe to my
newsletter right now
again that's dailywire.com matt walsh
report go there right now
right now go now it's time for our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we're
going to cancel all of the people who
are outraged by a certain new york times
article which was published at some
point
last week the title of the editorial is
how to rearrange your post-pandemic
friendscape and it was written by
someone named kate murphy now in the
article murphy talks about the changes
we might consider making to our social
lives
as we emerge from hibernation and enter
back into the post-pandemic world
before we get to the um controversial
part
here's a little bit of what she has to
say she says as pandemic restrictions
ease the united states and we may once
again
belly up to an all-you-can-eat buffet of
social activity the question is
will we pile our plates in gorge or be
more selective and stick to what
nourishes and sustains us psychologists
sociologists and evolutionary
anthropologists
say it behooves us to take a more
curatorial approach when it comes to our
friends
because who you hang out with determines
who you are quote we take it for granted
but having friends is exceedingly rare
in the animal kingdom
said dr nicholas christakis a professor
of social and natural science at yale
university
friendship is an evolutionary advantage
he says that allows us to form alliances
cooperate exchange ideas and learn from
one another having friends who encourage
stimulate and support you
is associated with improved immunity
lower blood pressure and higher
cognitive function having no friends
toxic friends or super
superficial friends not only can make
you feel insecure lonely or depressed
but also can accelerate cellular aging
and increase your risk of premature
death
now the only thing i find
objectionable here is the assumption
that we've all been hiding from the
world for the past year and now we have
to find a way to rebuild our lives from
scratch
that may be the case for some people
especially those living in liberal
cities but
it's not the case for me or a lot of
other people
i made absolutely no changes to my life
over the past year except for those that
i was
forced to make places closed down and so
i could not go into those places
but outside of uh outside of you know
that's outside of my control as for the
things i could control i carried on
exactly as i had before
these kinds of articles are yet another
indication that the people trying to
speak
to us and in many cases for us in the
mass media
are unable to successfully do either of
those things because they live in a
different universe
to use their language they can't relate
to our lived experience
that's why we're getting all of these
articles and cable news segments about
how to reclaim and
restart our lives it's a little
confusing because many of us never
stopped living our lives in the first
place
when somebody asks us what we'll do now
that the pandemic is over
our response is that we'll keep doing
exactly what we've been doing this
entire time
no significant change really but that's
not why people were outraged over the
article the outrage came from this
passage
quote indeed depressed friends make it
more likely you'll be depressed
obese friends make it more likely you'll
become obese and friends who smoke or
drink a lot make it more likely you'll
do the same
the reverse is also true you'll be more
studious kind and enterprising if you
consort with studious kind of
enterprising people
that's not to say that you should
abandon your friends when they're having
a hard time but it's
a good idea to be mindful of who you're
spending the majority of your time with
whether on or offline because your
friends prevailing moods values and
behaviors
are likely to become your own why what
are the hallmarks of good
foreground friends foremost they make
you feel better about the world than
yourself
so there it is people were very upset
about that they were upset
specifically that the writer murphy
murphy mentioned how you're more likely
to be depressed and obese if you
surround yourself with a bunch of sad
fat people
not her words exactly but that was the
general point there was
much outrage over that idea so much so
that near the new york times actually
deleted that passage that i just read
and added this editor's note a few days
ago it says quote
this article has been updated to remove
references to studies that examined
issues related to friendships and
obesity depression and tobacco and
alcohol use
the article's references to those
studies lacked sufficient context
and attribution and did not adequately
convey their relevance to the issues
discussed in the article
but what's wrong with what she said it's
true that we tend to mirror the
behaviors and attitudes of the people we
choose to spend
most of our time with it's true that you
should
consider that when deciding who you
spend time with
she specifically said that she's not
urging people to ditch
their depressed or obese friends on the
spot
she isn't suggesting that you do like a
weigh-in or something before you get
together
all right you're too fat get out of here
she isn't saying that if your friend
calls you up and says hey
man i'm feeling pretty down lately that
you should respond ew get away from me
man that's not quite the point the point
is simply that you should consider the
influences that you
allow into your life people who aren't
striving to better themselves or not
trying to improve as human beings are
content to you know simply wallow in
their laziness and misery all the time
those are the people that you definitely
don't need in your life that doesn't
describe every person who's overweight
or depressed obviously but it's a good
general rule to follow the problem
though
is that murphy misses her own point you
know she says that
our foreground friends the technical
term here is bff
those friends should make you feel
better about the world and yourself
well that's that's incorrect you
shouldn't be looking for friends who
simply make you feel better about
yourself in fact
if that's all you want then you'd
probably surround yourself with more
miserable ugly people because you look
so good in comparison
the job of a friend is not to make you
feel good about yourself the job of
anyone who loves you whether it's a
family member a friend a spouse whoever
is to make you a better person to help
you be a better person to help you
towards
holiness saint thomas aquinas said that
to love is to will the good of the other
all people who love you should be
willing the good for you
that doesn't mean delivering lectures
and sermons or anything like that it
just means that
they should want for you to be a good
person and to live a truly good and
healthy and happy life
and you need all of those things
together good healthy happy
if you choose just happy and that's all
you're focused on oftentimes you'll end
up with something
that is the opposite of healthy and good
so good should come first and then
healthy and happy
that's what you should want for yourself
and your friends a revealing indication
of what sort of friends you have and
this is mentioned in the article in
fairness
is how your friends react when genuinely
good things happen to you
or when you do a genuinely good thing
and you're enjoying the rewards of that
action
which you won't always enjoy the rewards
of a good action but sometimes you do
and a real friend will be happy for you
like really happy as if it happened to
them
but some quote friends will make it
about themselves they'll try to pull you
down into their misery and their failure
they'll make you feel almost guilty for
experiencing the good in life
those are the people you don't need they
should be dropped immediately
and with little concern for their
feelings a harsh wake-up call would
probably do them well
and i suspect that the people upset
about the article are mostly the bad
friend types
they're the ones who bring nothing to
their friendships
are nothing but a drain and a strain on
those around them
and they're constantly trying to drag
all of their supposed loved ones down
into the muck
of their own dreary self-centeredness
and they think they should have the
right to act like that
and still retain all of their
relationships
well they don't and that is all
generally the point the article was
trying to make i think
though it does miss the mark in some
important respects but not in the areas
that the critics are upset about so for
that reason
the critics are canceled and also i
guess the writer of the article
is cancelled and the new york times is
cancelled
and uh bad friends are canceled too so
throw them all out at once more
efficient that way
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright dailywire 2021. nickelodeon
tries to trans the kids
fauchi fights back against his critics
and joe biden undermines
our democracy check it out on the
michael knowles show